>>> JUST HOURS AGO, KENTUCKY
GOVERNOR ANDY BESHEAR CONFIRMED
AT LEAST FIVE PEOPLE HAVE DIED
IN EASTERN KENTUCKY.
HE SAID HALF OF THE STATE'S
COUNTIES ARE UNDERWATER IN WHAT
HE CALLED THE WORST FLOODING
DISASTER OF HIS LIFETIME.
EXTREME FLOODING CAUSES
DEVASTATION ACROSS THE NATION.
IN WEST VIRGINIA, THE GOVERNOR
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY
FOR SIX COUNTIES.
IN MISSOURI AND ARIZONA, FLASH
FLOODING PROMPTED ROAD CLOSURES
FOR RESCUES.
>> Reporter: A RACE TO RESCUE
THOSE STILL STRANDED IN EASTERN
KENTUCKY IN WHAT THE GOVERNOR
SAYS WILL END UP BEING ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT DEADLY
FLOODS IN YEARS.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, I EXPECT
DOUBLE DIGIT DEATHS IN THIS
FLOODING.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE RARELY
SEE.
>> Reporter: THE WATER SO HIGH
YOU CAN ONLY SEE THE ROOF OF
THIS HOME.
MANY OTHERS SUBMERGED UP TO THE
WINDOWS.
A RELENTLESS STALLED STORM FRONT
DUMPED MORE THAN 8 INCHES OF
RAIN IN THE AREA OVERNIGHT.
RAGING WATERS SWEPT AWAY HOMES
AND CARS.
>> I DIDN'T THINK IT WOULD GET,
YOU KNOW, THAT HIGH.
>> Reporter: THIS COUPLE BARELY
GOT OUT OF THEIR HOME IN TIME.
>> I SAID, YOU BETTER BE GETTING
YOU SOME CLOTHES AND BACKPACK
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO GET OUT OF
HERE.
BY THE TIME WE GOT UP TO THE
NEIGHBORS, TO TONY'S DOUBLE
WIDE, IT HAD WENT FROM THE BACK
OF THE TRAILER TO THE CARPORT.
>> Reporter: THE TOWN IS
SUBMERGED IN WATER.
ANDY BESHEAR DECLARED A
STATE-WIDE STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND ANNOUNCED THE FIRST
CONFIRMED DEATH, A WOMAN IN HER
80s IN PERRY COUNTY AND AT LEAST
TWO OTHERS.
LATER IN THE DAY, THE GOVERNOR
SAID THE DEATH TOLL HAD REACHED
AT LEAST EIGHT.
>> WE EXPECT THE LOSS OF LIFE.
HUNDREDS WILL LOSE THEIR HOMES,
AND THIS IS GOING YET ANOTHER
EVENT THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
NOT MONTHS BUT LIKELY YEARS FOR
MANY FAMILIES TO REBUILD AND
RECOVER.
>> Reporter: FLOODED, DOWNED
PHONE LINES KEPT RESIDENTS FROM
GETTING HELP IMMEDIATELY
OVERNIGHT.
>> I CAN'T GET TO THEM.
NOBODY CAN GET TO THEM.
>> HAVE YOU EVER EXPERIENCED
ANYTHING LIKE THIS?
>> NO, THIS HAS NEVER BEEN THIS
BAD.
>> Reporter: FLOOD WATERS RISING
OVER THE BRIDGE IN DOWNTOWN
WHIETS BORROW.
MANY ROADS IN THE AREA ARE
IMPASSABLE.
WHILE THE NATIONAL GUARD HAS
BEEN MOBILIZED TO RESCUE PEOPLE
AND PROVIDE AID, HUNDREDS ARE
EXPECTED TO LOSE THEIR HOMES.
>> IT HAPPENS.
I MEAN, IT'S BAD ENOUGH THE
FIRST TIME.
WE HAD INSURANCE.
THIS TIME WE DON'T.
BUT WE'LL MAKE IT.
WE ALWAYS DO WITH GOD'S HELP.
SO, JUST HAVE TO PICK YOURSELF
BACK UP.
AND THAT'S ALL WE CAN DO, YOU
KNOW?
>> JOE JOHNS JOINS ME NOW FROM
EASTERN KENTUCKY.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN DRIVING
THROUGH THE STATE.
CAN YOU JUST TALK MORE ABOUT
WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN SEEING?
>> Reporter: YEAH, YOU KNOW
WHAT, ANDERSON, I'VE GOT TO SAY,
I REALLY WASN'T PREPARED FOR
WHAT I HAVE BEEN SEEING.
AS YOU GET CLOSER AND CLOSER TO
HAZZARD, KENTUCKY, YOU SEE JUST
MILES AND MILES OF ROADS THAT
HAVE BEEN PARTIALLY ENCROACHED
BY WATER.
THERE ARE HOUSES PARTIALLY
SUBMERGED.
THERE ARE SOME FULLY SUBMERGED.
BUT I THINK THAT THE THING THAT
IS MOST CONCERNING IS SEEING
PEOPLE DRIVING INTO THE FLOOD
ZONE TRYING TO LOCATE FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO LIVED IN SOME OF THE
HOUSES THAT ARE CUT OFF FROM
EVERYBODY ELSE.
SO, IT'S A VERY CONCERNING
SITUATION FOR THIS PART OF
KENTUCKY.
FRANKLY, ANDERSON, I WORKED HERE
YEARS AGO RIGHT OUT OF COLLEGE
IN APPALACHIA AND NOT TOO FAR
FROM EASTERN KENTUCKY.
AND YOU'VE HEARD STORIES -- I'VE
HEARD MANY, MANY STORIES ABOUT
FLASH FLOODS AND THE KIND OF
DEVASTATION THEY CAUSE.
BUT THERE IS NOTHING LIKE
ACTUALLY SEEING WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
THE UPSIDE, THE ONLY UPSIDE, IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE PUTTING THEIR
ARMS AROUND EACH OTHER AND
TRYING TO HELP.
THEY ARE BLOCKING OFF ROADS TO
TELL OTHERS, DON'T GO DOWN
THERE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GIVE ADVICE
ABOUT HOW TO GET AROUND.
THAT'S THE ONE UPSIDE.
THE REST OF THIS, IT'S GOING TO
BE A LONG PROCESS FOR EASTERN
KENTUCKY, THIS PART OF EASTERN
KENTUCKY, AROUND HAZZARD, TO
COME BACK, ANDERSON.
>> THESE IMAGES WE'RE LOOK